we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p with a very interesting
question about improving the democratic
debates take a listen to this hi David
was the last Democratic presidential
candidate debates being largely up some
substantial and showing candidates
positions and policy aside from the
obvious need to reduce participants what
would you suggest change in the next
debate to improve this maybe there could
be better questions asked
thanks yeah I mean there's so much that
needs to happen to really improve the
quality of these debates number one we
do need fewer candidates that's going to
happen by the third debate so that is
going to take care of itself I think
that we need a narrower range of topics
so the debates should really be much
more highly focused so that number one
you can go into more depth on particular
topics and you can actually follow up
and moderators should be following up
with questions in order to really figure
out who knows in depth about these
issues because when you have a debate
format where there's ten people on the
stage not every candidate even gets to
answer every question the ones that do
get only 60 seconds only some candidates
get to issue a rebuttal and the ones
that do only get thirty seconds it's too
easy to skirt by without having to
actually demonstrate that you know
anything about these issues so I would
drastically narrow the focus of each
debate tax policy and inequality an
entire debate on that if you have only
five or six candidates on stage you can
actually give them you know several
minutes for their initial response and
then give other candidates several
minutes to rebut them structure it in a
way so that the moderators can
participate and actually ask follow-up
and probing questions without being
accused of partisanship or trying to
help one candidate or the other
everybody should be able to comment on
every question and the topics should be
drastically narrowed so that you have
many questions about one topic and none
of this is possible if the number of
participants isn't decreased which it
will be soon now will they will they
actually make these changes probably not
because these are what I call
the debates are structured to be sort of
argument porn that's really the role of
the moderators and we really learned
very little about the political
positions of our candidates when that's
the format we've got a great bonus show
for you today get instant access to the
bonus show by becoming a member or a
patron I'll speak to you then